hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play
forget-me-nots Annie god is a creepy
bear don't know what that's all about
anyway this is actually our game it's
not very recent but it was still been
highly recommended to me made on the
Unreal Engine if anyone's curious now I
don't seem to have a mouse cursor but
I'm trying to click on begin story here
I'm trying
oh come on I want to there we go see
Howard it's just a shadow ok not real
I think the shadows are real Teddy's
Teddy's are never bad how is how we're
doing today uh-huh
oh hi can you follow me please daddy we
need to go to my office now can Howard
come too of course
okie dokie yeah I don't know if this is
made by either an indie company or a
semi-professional one he's lying you
know that I know yeah who's lying honey
nothing
okay so hi Manny huh I don't like it
Howard this isn't real Annie oh we don't
lock up little girls Oh little girls are
never bad
I'm actually pretty confused this game
seems more involved than I thought it
was gonna be
Forget Me Not Annie okey-dokey
ah Carrie at home use telekinesis how
does I use telekinesis a hmm interesting
yeah I I'm actually surprised because I
had no idea goosey goosey gander whither
don't don't you wander what I can't
quite read that well enough then again I
can't really read it what what done haha
okay so I'm playing the role of a little
girl and uh uh that's my nanny
let's go okey-dokey oh I did he closed
y'all okay and there's a lot of writing
on the floor Wow
I uh I didn't know what I got myself
into here I'm just gonna carry on and
try not to die Russ edu he so a little
girl who's trapped in a mental
institution or some size
I heard something or a science facility
and on the team that's not good
pick it up hello okay what okay this
girl can do telekinesis I did that by
holding down the mouse and moving the
mouse wheel to push it back and forward
what why what am i running to the room
on the left the room on the left room on
the left room on the left
run wha it pointed me in the direction
Alex was the run one then ha ha
did I mention that I'm bad at games I
got a couple achievements I think that's
uh that's good
don't be okay
thank you creepy crazy teddy bear uh so
that did what what did that did need to
get over this no I need to pick that up
with my Teleca brainer what what do I
keep hearing a little um okay that open
that gate but I don't know how to get
over there I can't even pick that up
through there so I got to find something
ah
this world is a lot more manipulable
manipulatable than I thought
nip you late able manipulate a little
ball let's see I'm guessing I can stack
these up and climb over this fence here
this is my first guess everybody knows
how much I love to stock things
Christmas because everyone knows
stacking is a totally legitimate and
worthwhile endeavor in gay that's gonna
fall over
oh god it's gonna fall over it's gonna
fall it's gonna fall to the ball budge
no no ha ha bollocks
I can goddamn it oh oh yes slide right
off that's what I wanted
Oh God okay uh-huh
nod way oh god I hate stacking I'm
probably not even doing this the right
way oh god oh god oh god good perfect
deter ah okay I just get one more there
and then one more here I can uh I can go
I can uh I can do this whoa there's not
enough weight on this something seems
weird I don't know where I don't know
where I want I died and then I just went
here I don't know where here is
it wasn't my supposed to do it's not
sure cuz me stacking boxes here doesn't
seem to be getting that to go any
further okay
ah almost almost oh fudge oh no oh no oh
no oh no don't fall don't fall don't
fall don't fall
ah I do not like stacking I do not like
stamping
ahahahahahaha good good as new but not
as good okay I must be doing something
wrong here no no I don't even know how I
got in here help help I'm a little girl
oh my god
this must be why all these boxes are
here ha ha ha
god I hate stacking I hate stacking and
these boxes are so tiny these boxes are
so tiny there we go there we go finally
that's not what I was supposed to do was
it because now I'm trapped over here
well I even saw the pose you know like
achoo
uh-huh let's you you this this one will
be a bad okay like this one would be a
bad one I've got a Swedish guy over
there but I don't care I don't care I
don't think I I don't think I did
something right just like my whole life
I haven't done something right there's a
chair wait there's a chair ah where did
it go did it just evaporate that's great
this is great this is my favorite this
is my favorite ever I go into a room
that I don't even know how the hell I
got in here I go find some crap that I
don't even know what to do with I can't
even move these chairs
I gotta somehow push this button down
keep it down I got it
mother [ __ ] [ __ ] mother
ha ha I've also had a really bad day
today guys
really bad day today so ha ha ha how do
I get I don't even know where to I don't
I don't even oh yeah we all got problems
hey look it's just like some of these
boxes just evaporate into nothingness
no big boxes ain't gonna do anything
these boxes are seriously not gonna do
anything I don't have any like menu or
anything that I can use I don't have any
special powers whoa whoa oh where did
you come from
what what done uh hi you kidding me you
couldn't be Howard you're kidding me
Howard Howard you kidding me Kim here
get him out
what that why won't you swap there we go
get these boxes off here get him off get
him off get him off get him off get get
him off get him off and how was I
supposed to know that you could get how
hard Wow Thank You Howard
you stay there now is that pressing it
down good you stay there
leggo up here and these don't fall don't
fall don't fall yes finally God ah my
goodness no actually I might be an idiot
there I'm an idiot because I believe we
need to stay together okay all right I
pressed the right click yeah if I'd have
been able to hear the game audio I would
have heard his voice say hey don't
forget me
hello where am i what am i doing
what is that aah oh no aah oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no I don't want to
be here anyway find us okay
courage okay newsprint newsprint on the
floor Wars and famine makes me snore
from the agent of story flows a tragic
murder you shall know oh well screw you
too then I for yep interesting it's like
a puzzle platformer horror game who's
crying
who's a big bubble blowing baby big
bubble blowing baby blue little doll
yeah whatever okay okay I don't get in
there get in there get in there
yeah it's just beyond my reach where'd
it go where'd it go
Oh what done it's like portal actually
this does remind me a lot of [ __ ]
make that ha ha what's down there death
by falling into the abyss Howard has
been unsummoned oh hi Howard
hi you're looking mighty snazzy today
okay so that's pressing that I'm just
pressing that if I Howard Howard don't
be stopping Howard how hard hard hard ah
ah
the colors Howard what did you say
you're a dick oh yeah I agree what that
oh matching the colors okay ha
get down er get your fat fluffy ass down
here I need you and yeah okay apparently
this just in markiplier is bad at games
this just in breaking news markiplier
sucks balls big sweaty balls come on
okay so I'm not gonna summon him till I
get down there but then again I don't
really know how to get breaking news
markiplier died again
analysts say yeah I'm not surprised
alright so that but I'm here and I go
how hard hi now what did that do what
did you do Howard what did you do go
away Howard okay so that G nothing
Howard you're a weirdo yeah hahahaha no
no no I'm sorry hard just away b yo ha
Howard's first demise I think I put him
through about seven yeah oh I did make
it Howard
come here what done okay and that's the
two blues are going now can I get these
in there somehow
oh yeah alright that did not work good
job bot hi oh god I didn't realize this
would be such a puzzler alright I all my
criticisms aside this actually is a very
interesting game if I was you know if I
wasn't extremely angry today for no
particularly
oh if I wasn't extremely angry today for
no particular reason than I might I
might enjoy this game a little more but
as it stands I'm in a bad mood and
that's all that's all for now um there's
obviously just a first try I'll explain
why I'm in a bad mood later today in a
v-log but ah that's all a whole nother
story so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next bye bye
Oh